cette épreuve vous révèle tout l'amour
et l'admiration
oui en effet que soulève de ce site
oui j'ai écouté on est on est vraiment
inondé d'une avalanche de messages
d'amour d'espoir de support de réconfort
alors au nom de mon frère dominique et
de les parents et moi même bien entendu
et de ses amis proches
j'aimerais vraiment exprimer toute ma
gratitude sait on est porté par tous et
je vous remercie beaucoup de
m'accueillir ici pour pour en faire en
faire part aux gens et il veut dire
continuer de m'écrire c c'est peut-être
un petit mot pour vous mais pour moi
c'est toute la différence qu'on va lire
et relire et isabelle quand elles
peuvent ouvrir une quel message don
permet non ne riez vous laisser
peut-être au nom d'isabelle mais encore
une fois la prudence je pense que le
port du casque est toujours de mise
à vélo mais en voiture le port de la
tête est toujours de mise aussi je pense
qu'il faut faire preuve de prudence et
poète insouciant pas intelligent là le
partage de la route
le partage de la route mais la voiture
est une arme c'est ce que je dis à mes
enfants maintenant qu'ils conduisent
j'ai envie d'être très prudent mais
écoutez en même temps je vais pas
m'enflammer dans aucun des postes n'est
pas du tout ma place de faire ce qui
suppose le message ultime lancer un
message de gratitude et de
reconnaissance et de hid
oui c'est sûr je veux exprimer mes
remerciements à tous ceux qui qui ont
déferlé cette sympathie incommensurable
oui c'est réconfortant c'est très
réconfortant et ça nous ça nous porte
comme famille ça nous ça nous soulève ça
nous ça nous supportent